suivant s'il vous plaît d'autres noms
joker ou avez vous été blessés en france
non je voudrais dire à quelle partie du
corps il s'est fracturé le crâne quand
il était avec son unité
et quand cela se produit vous ne voyez
plus rien je vois des taches de lumière
ou arrivé à me libérer de tout ça
c'était plus difficile pour toi
ce n'était qu'une moitié des jamais
m'ouvre le crâne ça va me tuer la radio
n'a pas révélé de fracture récente donc
on a un ancien combattant invalidant
parfait de santé le patient déclare qui
ne sait plus s'il rêve ou s'il est
éveillé vous voulez dire schizophrénie
georges des voeux à la palais j'ai fait
que chez les mots arts pendant deux ans
un lot si ça ne vous ennuie pas
j'aimerais en savoir un peu plus quel
est votre nom 21 au canada et puyol
puis-je vous demander ce que ça veut
dire de dire tout le monde parle de
l'est combien de temps tu vas rester ici
à moi
ne prenez pas mal surtout mais les
blancs général ne nous aiment pas
beaucoup
soyez tranquilles ces deux plans pas
prêt
de quoi parle je n'en ai pas la moindre
idée vous pouvez fermer les yeux et me
dire la première chose que vous voyez
cet homme n'a aucun trouble mental de
dessin vous suffisent pour le diagnostic
blackfoot penser que les rêves s'élevait
à prédire l'avenir
non nous croyons que les rêves servent à
éclairer le passé
pourquoi vous ne pas baisser
si un homme continue à hanter c'est sans
rien dire jour après jour ça s'empile
depuis
un beau jour c'en est trop c'est semer à
déporter